[music]
>> Well, friends, as you can see this is a
very special episode of Advent Defense
League. I would like to very special
guest of ours.
I I truly believe that you have blessed
and um for those who don't know him, I'm
sure he's easy to find online.
Um
He's I I consider him probably one of
the most foremost speakers of
Seventh-day Adventism at this time.
Absolutely. Um and he has a
Is that the right word?
A malcontent.
They say.
Right? [laughter]
I suppose by his side to uphold his hand
Aaron Yeah. to uphold his hand at least
in my in my estimation. Right? So,
um friends, I'm sure you guys know who
he is. Um I will say this and I'm sure
he doesn't know this, but I'm sure he
hears this all the time. That series
that he did, the Total Onslaught series,
was probably the one of the foundations
of
my love as far as the Bible is
concerned.
The reason why we are talking about
this.
There is
and at the Advent Defense League, one of
the things we speak about a lot is we
speak about the Sabbath, which is great.
And I believe that's one of the um
one of the message that needs to
continue to be brought out and you know,
defended and all those things, but
I remember there's a quote A Great
Controversy and Jason, if you can bring
that up. Um Great Controversy page 588.
Right? As he speaks on something that I
think is very important and I want to
make sure that you know, we at the
Advent Defense League that we bring the
whole thing. Can we actually go to the
previous paragraph?
And then we'll start from there.
Just to make sure that we don't kind of
miss anything.
And then what we'll do is we'll go into
it. We'll probably read two or three
paragraphs and then
we'll introduce our special guest.
Yet this very class
put forth the claim that the
fast-spreading corruption is largely
attributable to the desecration of the
so-called Christian Sabbath and that the
enforcement of Sunday observance would
greatly improve the morals of society.
This claim is especially urged in
America
where the doctrine of the true Sabbath
has been
most widely preached.
Here the temperance work, one of the
most prominent and important of moral
reforms, is often combined with the
Sunday movement. And the advocates of
the latter represent themselves as
laboring to promote the highest interest
of society and those who refused
to unite with them are denounced as the
enemies of temperance and reform.
But the fact that a movement to
establish error is connected with a work
which is in itself good is not an
argument in favor of the error. We may
disguise poison by mingling it with
wholesome food,
but we do not change its nature. Mercy,
that's that's that's a serious statement
right there.
On the contrary, it is rendered more
dangerous
as it is more likely to be taken
unawares.
It is one of Satan's devices to combine
with falsehood just enough truth to give
it plausibility.
If that ain't true, I don't know what
is.
The leaders of the Sunday movement may
advocate reforms which the people need,
principles which are in harmony with the
Bible, yet while there is while while
while there is with these a requirement
which is contrary to God's law,
His servants cannot unite with them.
Nothing can justify them in setting
aside the commandments of God for the
praise of men.
Now here's the main thrust.
Through the two great errors,
the immortality of the soul and Sunday
sacredness, Satan will bring the people
under his deceptions. While the former
lays the foundation of spiritualism, the
latter creates a bond of sympathy with
Rome.
The
Protestants of the United States will be
foremost in stretching their hands
across the gulf to grasp the hand of
spiritualism.
They will reach the reach over the abyss
to clasp hands with the Roman power and
under the influence of this threefold
union, this country will follow in the
steps of Rome in trampling on the rights
of conscience. One more paragraph.
As spiritualism more closely imitates
the nominal Christianity Oh, imitate.
I'm sorry. I didn't say irritate. Mercy.
As spiritualism more closely imitates
the nominal Christianity of the day, it
has greater power to deceive and
ensnare.
Satan himself is converted converted
Yeah, converted after the modern order
of things. He will appear in the
character of an angel of light. Through
the angel agency of spiritualism,
miracles will be wrought. The sick will
be healed and many undeniable wonders
will be performed.
And as the spirits profess faith in the
Bible and manifest respect for the
institutions of the church, their work
will be accepted as a manifestation of
divine power. And we'll and we'll we'll
stop right there. So, as you can see,
you know, friends, that we we talk about
in the Advent Defense League, we talk
about the state of the dead a lot
actually. Some of the work done on it
and also
Sabbath.
But I know more focus people focus on
the Sabbath because you know, that's
naturally in our in Seventh-day
Adventists. So, today I I would like for
us to really focus on that
that immortality of the soul or the
spiritualism aspect and help us get a
better understanding. And uh
we got two individuals
um Moses and Aaron
of this day to help us
understand that way better.
So, without further ado, we introduce
Dr. Walter Veith and Dr. Martin Smith.
Hi there.
>> Hello. Gentlemen,
how are you guys doing?
We're doing fine. Very well, thanks.
Nice to be here.
Man, it's great to see you guys. And
yes, and um we're going to get right
into this to this study.
Again, you know, I I'm I'm really
looking forward to this and I I'm sure
that what they have to share will be
really a blessing to us. Let us pray
and uh let's get let's get right into
it.
Uh let's pray.
>> [clears throat]
>> Father, we thank you for this time that
we get to spend with you studying your
word.
For the safety of your people.
And so now I pray that you may bless
your men servants to actually speak the
message in clarity
and for our understanding.
I pray that your spirit may fall upon
them fresh and give them power from on
high.
Allow us to understand it clearly. Let
there be no doubt what is it that you're
trying to convey. And I pray that you
may be transformational transformational
to those who may listen thereby.
Be with us now. Forgive us of any sin
that we committed that would block these
prayers from going up.
And magnify
We ask all this in Jesus' name.
Amen.
Dr. Veith, you can take it away.
Take it away.
All right.
>> Yes.
Well, where does spiritualism start?
It starts right there in Genesis.
Uh God warns the
couple there there that there is an
enemy
and that enemy approaches Eve at the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
And he he uses a a technique to
influence her mind.
So, the influence of mind upon mind can
be based on good things
and it can be based on evil things.
If you want to coerce people or subject
them to your way of thinking
and you use techniques in order to
further that, then it is from the evil
side.
God never coerces.
God draws you. He gives you information.
He allows you to make a decision.
He doesn't subvert your consciousness
into an altered state so that his will
can be impressed upon you so that you do
it like an automaton. So, that's the
difference basically between the two.
And the devil used hypnotism in the
Garden of Eden
in order to get Eve to see his point of
view.
Well, just to make sure that everybody's
on the same page, what exactly is
hypnotism?
Well, hypnotism is basically where you
place a person in an altered state of
consciousness
and then you install thoughts or
uh ideas into the mind and get people to
react accordingly.
So, they say you can use it for good,
you can use it for bad. The answer as
far as I'm concerned is it's never good
because you must never allow your mind
to be subject to someone else's mind
without having control [clears throat]
over what you are doing or thinking.
Yes.
>> So, any anybody who wants to subject you
so that you become subject to that
person's way of thinking is not from
God. Never.
I understand. But the thing that's
important to realize is how many
different
um forms there are of hypnotism and how
easy you can think oh, hypnotism is a
guy swinging a pendulum and getting you
into a trance.
That's how you think, but
just watching or uh uh a movie can
hypnotize you. Just what If you look at
If you look at the definition of
hypnotism,
then they will tell you it's a
flickering image on a screen in a dark
room.
And that is exactly what a movie is, for
example. It puts you in an
into another reality
and you become steeped in that reality.
In other words, you lose contact with
reality and go into an alternative
world.
Even though you are fully conscious, you
are uh drawn into it to such an extent
that if something happens, you scream
your head off if it's a horror movie,
for example. Or if there's uh another
scene, you become involved in it in a
sickly sentimental way. You Either way,
you become sucked into the narrative and
into the form so that you actually
become part of of that scenario.
Dangerous portions of that can be when
you're in for instance certain sermons
in the church. And music are playing and
you know, the way that the pastor is
speaking. All of these things so that
you are susceptible to any message that
he wants to get
>> And then if the if the ambiance and the
feelings
are heightened under those
circumstances,
then you can be led to believe that this
is the working of the Holy Spirit and
therefore it is acceptable even though
it might be everything but acceptable.
Oh, doc. Can I Can I ask you a question
now? Just quick question. So, are you
saying that you know, a lot of times,
especially when the minister is about to
give the appeal, they they start playing
the music and they kind of almost kind
of set the stage for someone to give
their life
over to their God as far as through the
appeal.
Are we saying that that's also a
negative
thing as well or
>> It depends. You see, you can make an
appeal to the mind
and there's nothing wrong with making an
appeal to the heart at the same time.
But once it becomes coercive, then
there's a problem. Let me give you an
example. Have you ever walked into a
casino?
Ever been in a casino?
>> [laughter]
>> Been in one on TV. All right.
It doesn't matter. Even if you don't go
and gamble, I mean, just walking into a
casino, the first thing you will notice
it that is there certain hum
of sound running in the background. And
it's a it's a very monotonous sort of
like a mantra sound.
And it keeps continuing in the
background.
And that puts you into another frame of
mind so that you actually lose control
over your cognitive ability to
distinguish Wow. between what you are
doing and what they want you to do.
So that you get lost in this and you go
into this altered state of consciousness
and you just keep on chucking money into
that slot machine or you keep playing
your cards and the music sort of puts
you into that altered state that you
cannot really logically distinguish
between what you are doing and what
you're supposed to do.
So if you have this kind of background
music to create an atmosphere
to induce you to do something,
it might not actually be from the heart.
It might be a coercive force.
So, yes, there's nothing wrong with an
appeal. There's nothing wrong with
appealing to the heart, but sometimes we
can push it so far that it becomes
questionable. Let's put it that way.
I'll say.
Okay. I So
I know
there's some questions. I mean, since
we're on the subject, I don't know if
you wanted to take this questions
related to what you're saying now or did
you want to wait towards the end or
Whatever. Do it what however you want to
do it. Throw the question. So,
I mean, I think you probably answered
this a little bit, but can the enemy
hypnotize you without a human agent?
Yes, he can. Absolutely, he can.
When I was in involved in the
spiritualistic world,
then
number one, you could do self-hypnosis.
There's no other agent present when you
do self-hypnosis.
Uh there are very common techniques as
to how to do self-hypnosis.
And you can do other spiritualistic
things like out-of-body experiences
and they are actually very real,
but they are hypnotic implants. They're
actually a movie playing in your mind
that has been instilled by another
agent, namely a demon.
And that becomes so real that it's like
a 3D movie.
You are you are watching it and you
become so animated that it is really
your experience when actual fact, it's
just a simulation taking place in your
mind.
So you can you can leave your body and
you can float above your body and you
can do all kinds of things like, you
know, go to different rooms, go to
different planets, do whatever you want
and it plays out in your mind like
reality.
And when you come back out of that
state, you absolutely believe that you
had that experience, but you haven't
left the room.
And you haven't had a spirit come out of
your body. You've just had a literal 3D
experience implanted in your mind.
Oh, sorry, Walter. I mean, sorry.
Martin, did you want to add to that? I
was just thinking
now that you mentioned that this there's
no spirit leaving your body. That's also
maybe
because that's very important
to identify
your spirit. Yes. Because that's where
spiritualism really gets a hold.
Spiritualism, as Martin says, starts
with you shall surely not die.
That implies that you are a a dual
entity, a physical entity and a
spiritual entity, both of which have
human consciousness.
And that is not true because
if you study the Bible,
then you have to get a very clear grip
on what the state of the dead is.
Uh I mean, I I had in my life
communication with demonic forces, with
spiritual forces
that you thought were were good.
And some of them you thought, well, they
were not so good. That I mean, that that
happened, but who were you talking to?
Uh when I had attempts to speak to
deceased people like my deceased
parents, for example,
I got answers from that other from those
entities on the other side.
But they were speaking
in their behalf pretending to be someone
else.
And there again, [clears throat]
if you do not understand the state of
the dead, that the dead know nothing,
that they will never return unto their
house, then you cannot be fooled into
believing that this spirit is haunting
the house because he's he's restless or
whatever. Because the dead know nothing.
Their thoughts perish. They are in a
state of deep unconsciousness.
It's called death.
And they will have no part under the sun
until there is a resurrection.
And if you understand that, then you
have crossed the great barrier. But even
then, even if you understand it,
there are still many dangers lurking in
other forms of spiritualism
that can accost you and bring you into a
false sense of of religious euphoria
like spiritual formation
or Jesuit spirituality.
You can you can know that the dead are
asleep and know nothing and you can
still be hooked by these other forms of
spiritualism. Especially when you want
to dive deeper in
get a
greater knowledge of something, even
biblical studies. Yes, or you want to
have a greater spiritual experience.
Uh
to the law and to the testimony, if they
speak not according to this word,
then you have a problem. That's a
serious warning that there are entities
that people mutter like in Isaiah
chapter 8 verse 19 and 20.
If if your criteria
on if your criteria are not based on
scripture,
but on sentiment and
you will be led astray.
Just to read it so that people know. And
when they shall say unto you, seek unto
them that have familiar spirits and unto
wizards that peep and that mutter,
should not a people seek unto their God
for the living to the dead? To the law
and to the testimony, if they speak not
according to this word, it is because
there is no light in them. Exactly.
So, God God seriously forbids speaking
to spirit entities.
It's called necromancy, speaking to the
dead.
And
>> [clears throat]
>> God's people were
guilty in terms of that because Saul
went and spoke to
an entity which he believed was Samuel.
But if you know your Bible, then Samuel
was
asleep. He was dead and he would never
return to his house and you weren't
supposed to listen to anything that an
entity like that said. So, had he done
that, he would have been safeguarded
from the pitfall that he fell into.
Pastor White, there there's a question
that I really would like to know the
answer to. And I think this is something
that needs to be really made clear.
In the [snorts] Bible, what does the
word spirit mean? Because
when when we speak to a lot of people,
they're saying, "Oh, your spirit goes to
God." And
you know, or or something else.
Can we come up with a clear explanation
of what spirit means in the Bible? What
is spirit?
>> the Bible talks about in the Old
Testament about ruach.
That is breath.
Now,
if you're familiar with biology,
then you know that everybody that is
alive has a metabolism.
In other words, there is an exchange
[clears throat]
of oxygen and oxidation processes which
take place within your system
which define that you are alive. In
other words, you are alive and you are
breathing.
And this is a very interesting point.
You see, this breath, this life that God
has given to you,
is something that we cannot really
understand by itself.
If you have a dead body, it has all the
components of a living body.
It has all the chemicals. It has all the
necessary oxidative
organelles in it that it needs to stay
alive, but once it has stopped
metabolizing, it is dead.
And you will not get it back
[clears throat and music] again. So,
that is something that is called life
and we don't have it within ourselves.
There's only one that has life within
him himself and that is God.
So, if you read John chapter 1, it says,
"In him was life
and the life was the light of the
world." So, life you find in him. He
says, "I lay it down and I take it up
again. No one takes it from me."
And he has it within himself. So,
according to the scripture,
God alone has immortality
and has life within himself.
And he gives it to us on condition. And
he's not vague about it.
Right there in Genesis, he gave the
condition. The day you transgress what I
have told you explicitly,
you lose the right to that life.
And this immortality is something that
belongs to God
and he gives it to them whom he will.
So, life is conditional. So, this
metabolism, this ruach, this breath
is something that God gives and God
takes it away if you do not meet the
conditions
and that's what the scriptures teach.
Yeah, it's in Genesis 2:7,
when God breathed into the nostrils of
Adam, it does not say
that he received
a living soul.
He became
>> Yes. So, who is the entity?
We are the entity.
And you know, the world likes to think
of us as a duality, the physical and the
spiritual and that they can live
independently or with each other. If you
are alive and if you are dead, well,
then the spirit carries on living. No,
the soul, the nephesh that sins, it
shall die. The Bible is very clear. The
soul is the living entity of the flesh
plus the ruach plus the life that God
has given us.
We need this computer that God has put
into our minds.
There is not some airy-fairy cloud out
there that continues after we have died.
This is what is alive. This is the
entity that God is dealing with.
Amen.
Ready?
So, so now So, extending now from Adam,
so we see that there was hypnotism,
which I never looked at it that way. So,
uh I'm glad you guys brought that out
because I I had no idea. And I'm going
to be honest with you, Martin, I I
actually
did think
>> [laughter]
>> hypnotism was more of the devil. I'm
I I have
I honestly have no idea what hypnotism
really is. I'm glad you actually shared
that. And you you you brought up also
how Saul had this kind of, you know,
leaning towards spiritualism as well.
In in in regards to the to the stream of
time, what are some other examples that
we can see that may not be readily
available or readily understood where
spiritualism was was seen
as far as the scriptures are concerned?
Well,
you read in the Old Testament that you
shouldn't you you must not have contact
with these familiar spirits, right?
Now, in spiritualism, in the in the
pagan religions,
uh they had their soothsayers. They had
their wizards. They had You read about
them in Daniel. He lists them all. You
had your Chaldeans, but you had all of
these others as well that would be
stargazers, astrologers, wizards, you
name them.
And they Wizards are known to be able to
cast spells, for example.
But a spell requires a go-between.
It requires a spiritual entity to go and
do whatever the the spell predicted. If
you place a curse on someone and you say
they're going to get sick, then some
entity must
facilitate that disease or that demise
that comes along.
So, you are actually invok- invoking a
demon to go and do your dirty work for
you when you are a wizard. And in pagan
religions, where their idols were,
they believed that they received the
oracles of God when associated with
these idols. So, they would sit in a
trance-like state and receive messages,
uh
locutions or internal messages or even
verbal loud messages
from these entities.
And [clears throat] that is all
spiritualism because who were they
talking to? They were talking to demons.
Okay,
take it
Sorry. Take
other cultures
where, let's say, African culture,
which has voodoo as as its basis, where
you create an altered state of
consciousness by specific drum beats,
for example. We do that with our music
to create that altered state of
consciousness.
So, anything that is repetitive or very
rhythmic is something that puts you into
that state. And they claim to be in
contact with their ancestors
and can speak to the ancestors. Now,
people look at that and say, you know,
that's pagan.
But in Catholicism, you have exactly the
same thing because they communicate with
the saints, which are also dead.
Or who are also dead.
So, it is it is uh it is something that
is very common in the religious world,
but it is all actually demonology.
And [clears throat] the And the scary
thing is it's also in Christianity, like
you've mentioned in Catholicism, but
they're also in evangelical churches.
Uh
we can mention speaking in tongues.
Um it's a form of spiritualism. Slain in
the spirit.
And when you see some of these, I don't
know if you've ever seen um Benny Hinn
or even Paula White,
the advisor to Trump, um
when they speak in tongues and they
throw and shout fire over the people and
the people fall over and all of these
things.
These are all
And then
it's accommodated by music, though. So,
all of these are hyp- not tick um
elements [clears throat] and putting you
in a state of mind and then spiritualism
is the result.
>> And result is always the same.
The experience becomes the norm
rather than the word.
Now, if you take speaking in tongues for
example, it's not something that is only
found in evangelical environments. You
find it in Hinduism, you find it in in
many forms of pagan religions, you find
them in spiritualism.
This is a very common theme. You find it
in
uh UFO
experiences.
Speaking in tongues
is a muttering and peeping that makes no
sense.
Is it Corinthians?
>> Okay. Yes, 1 Corinthians 14 gives a
pretty detailed
uh
rendition of what the problem is there.
And then of course, the big problem
today is visualization
and uh meditation
>> meditation
Now, to meditate on the word is one
thing because when you meditate on the
word, you are reading scripture and
trying to understand what the verse is
telling you. And thinking about it. Yes,
you can go further and say, "Okay, what
is the typological aspect? How does it
relate to a greater reality in the
future?" So, typology plays a very
important part in your deliberation.
And just thinking about the scriptures
and what they mean and how they apply to
your life, that's all meditation.
But once meditation becomes divorced
from the writing of the word
and becomes involved in the reality of a
communication with some form of
either spirituality or an actual
encounter
then we start getting into
Jesuit spirituality.
Where you actually [clears throat] start
speaking to other entities and those
entities inform you rather than the word
and they will even contradict the word.
Mhm.
And then you get some
I don't know if you guys have ever seen
the
the series called The Chosen.
Yeah, I started watching and then I
stopped. Okay. I you know, I I I have a
thing. I I can't look at anything you
know, like that. It's just I'm like, I'd
rather read the Bible. So, I I
personally haven't seen it, but I know
about it. I'm very proud of you.
So, [laughter]
it's excellent. I haven't I've also I
think I've watched half of an episode.
And then
um but
we've
shown some of those videos by admission
of the creators of it, of the actors in
it and all of it.
That is done by Ignatian
spirituality.
Uh visualizations
and as soon as
um
you know,
there's such a thin line because or not
even a thin line, it it's used to say
it's Christian.
And then as soon as
this meditation starts running with
visualizations, with your senses
and all of these things to get a better
experience
and then to read
for how many times, maybe 20 times the
same passage over and over and over and
over and see if you can find something.
This is all very dan-
can get very dangerous.
Let me put it in a nutshell.
If you have to practice a technique
in order to get uh
you know, the attention of God
then there is a problem. Yeah. If you
have to sit in a particular way
if you have to you know, one of the very
common ways in which people like to sit
is uh you know, like yoga or
uh the lotus position or any one of
those
if you have to empty your mind Mhm. in
other words, empty it of whatever
thoughts you have if you have to follow
certain breathing exercises, any
technique or if you have to repeat over
and over a particular mantra without
having any cognitive connection with it
or if you have to walk a maze or any
technique to get the attention of God is
from the devil.
If I can put it as bluntly as that.
Because your association with God
is the same as your association with
your best friend or with your wife.
What you want is you want to have a
direct one-to-one communication
and God will answer you through his
word.
He won't whisper sweet nothings in your
ear.
To the law and to the testimony, if they
speak not according to this word, there
is no light in them. So, if you have
questions for God
he will take you through his scripture.
>> Yeah. And he will show you. If you want
to know about the Sabbath, when when
when I first started realizing that the
Sabbath was important
uh particularly my wife was ahead of me
when it came to the Sabbath.
You know, people always thought that you
know, I influenced my wife. No, she
influenced me.
So,
when she started studying the Bible to
see you know, what does the Bible say
about the Sabbath? It was amazing
because everything she opened up talked
about the Sabbath. And if you talk about
another issue and you're really
interested in getting an answer from
God, he will give you the answers. You
don't have to use your senses. You know,
you always said if you want to
hear what God says, read your Bible out
loud.
>> [laughter]
>> Then you will hear what you hear. Then
you will hear it.
You see, Ignatian spirituality
Ignatian spirituality says you must use
all your senses.
So, that includes something like the
sense of smell.
Now, you know what it that can become
erotic.
And you can have all kinds of fantasies
of you know, a perfume or something that
pervades the air.
The sense of touch, the gentle touch
all of your senses, the soft spoken
word, any one of those. I have listened
to many many spiritualists
in my life when I wasn't not a
Christian.
And I'm always amazed if you you listen
to these new age entities, these
ascended masters, the way they speak.
They have these soft melodious voices
and they talk to you, my dear one. And
they are they are so nauseating if you
if you ask me now.
But
you are so drawn into it because you are
constantly being flattered.
Now, flattery is one of the ways in
which Satan
that's twists your mind to come onto his
wavelength.
And mercy flattery is actually a
dangerous thing. If you read the spirit
of prophecy, she warns against flattery.
And you have to actually guard yourself
because it's easy to be puffed up if
you're constantly flattered.
>> [clears throat]
>> And the Bible says, "Woe to you if all
men speak well of you." So, I'm glad
there are a few enemies that speak badly
about us.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm I'm sure you have many.
I'm sure you guys have many.
Go go ahead, Jason. You want to say
something? You know,
Pastor uh there's a lot of questions on
this subject um that I would if we could
really tackle them because you were
talking about um meditation, but this is
a
this is a question similar to that.
What about breath work, deep breathing
with calming your mind and from
intrusive thoughts?
I think that's similar to what you were
just talking about perhaps. All right.
Uh
let's ask a question. If you are highly
stressed
is it wrong to do deep breathing
exercises?
No. For a few minutes maybe.
I'm a pianist
and um I I've done like concerts, like
real classical concert pianist piano
music and deep breathing does help me
calm down my heart rate. Yes.
>> But um but I'm thinking about the notes
I'm about to play. All right. And God,
you know
And but do you do that constantly? For
how long do you do it? It's so it's not
a something that you do
to
that you every time you have to do. You
don't continue doing it for
forever. No. So, to get yourself Yeah,
so calm and then carry on. It's
perfectly fine to do breathing exercises
to calm yourself, to
to settle your nerves, to you know, get
yourself onto an even keel again.
That's fine. Once you start using the
deep breathing in order to create an
altered state of consciousness
then it becomes problematic. So, there's
often this fine line and the devil
always likes to you know, jump the fine
line.
And then you can take it in a step
further and you can start doing breath
prayers.
And once you have to start doing breath
prayers and you know, breathe in and
breathe out. Their favorite one is to
say that God's name is actually a
breath. You know, Yahweh. It's Yah.
Yah.
So, you're breathing the name. You're
actually saying the name of God and God
is in that name. And eventually you whip
yourself into a state of euphoria and
you think that you now have a direct
telephone connection with God and you
don't need the word anymore.
You are on another level.
Now, that's where the scary part comes
in and that's what they also acknowledge
in The Chosen.
95% you must actually watch some of
those videos is not from the Bible.
It's from sitting around getting
in a in a in a group or maybe even on
this with themselves
doing all these exercises and then
hearing what the spirit tells you. And
may and what this guy will tell you.
This is when spiritism takes over. Now,
imagine they've got an app out, right?
Martin, they have an app. Halo. No.
Yeah, well, is it Halo, yeah?
>> Halo is a prayer app, yeah.
>> Yeah, they've got various apps which
help you to connect to God.
You know what? Yeah, the prayer app,
Halo. God is a prayer away.
And the definition of prayer is speaking
to God as with a friend.
I don't need an app to [clears throat]
communicate with
your loved ones.
Now, I know that today the world uses an
app because they're sitting at the
breakfast table talking to each other
via text. So, they need an app an app to
talk to each other.
And it was it was not so in the
beginning. They didn't have a cell phone
in order to communicate. They talked
directly to them to each other. So, once
you start
needing an app in order to speak to God,
you have a problem.
Can you use an app to get a better
knowledge of God? Of course, you can use
e-Sword and you can use all kinds of of
apps to, you know, get more information
about God. So, there's always something
good and there is something evil.
And you have to
navigate through that mess.
But by the way, I just so that you know,
there's a
there's an inside joke with us at ADL
with e-Sword. We love e-Sword. But some
of us like Blue Letter Bible, so I
always tell the people get your e-Sword.
So, if you see people get excited when
you say the word e-Sword that you just
know why.
>> [clears throat]
[laughter]
>> But that's just something an inside ADL
joke. Okay.
Thank you for that, Pastor. Uh we love
e-Sword as well. Makes life a lot easier
in many many many places, yes.
>> [laughter]
>> Praise the Lord. Amen. Praise the Lord.
So
I I um so so Doc, I I actually wanted to
touch a little bit as far as what you
were talking about before as far as the
um the speaking in tongues portion.
Right, I brought it up. But um now I
think there's a lot of people that
probably assume that how can it be that
bad visiting how do how does it how does
it show
and maybe you spoke about it earlier,
but I guess I was trying my best to
understand it. It just kind of went over
my head a little bit, so I need a little
bit more more information or
understanding for that.
How does the speaking in tongues portion
really show our form of spiritual
connection to speaking to demons or so
on and so forth? Like how how does that
work?
Well, if you go through Corinthians, 1
Corinthians, then
Paul is constantly contrasting
truth with error.
My favorite word in chapter 14 is the
word but.
>> [laughter]
>> Because he he will
uh
sort of give a scenario
and then say, "But." And then he will
give the antithesis. What does God
really say about it?
You know, he says, "I praise God that I
speak in tongues more than others." But
what kind of tongues was he talking
about? Now, the only way that you can
really
define that is you must go to the first
definition
in order to understand what he's talking
about. You cannot use a definition out
of
context without a example of a direct
definition of what tongues is about.
And you will find that in Acts chapter
2.
Where it is clearly defined that they
were speaking
te idia dialekto in the mother tongue of
those that were listening to them.
In other words, even with the nuances
and the pronunciations,
they were speaking as though they were
born into that language.
And then it lists all those lan-
languages, whether it was Arabian or
whether it was this or that and the
other.
So, the clear definition is that it was
a language that they received in order
to communicate
the wonderful workings of God. In other
words, to spread the gospel. Now, you
get to another chapter
and there's a statement, you know, when
you're speaking you're actually speaking
mysteries, et cetera, et cetera. And
then it comes with a but.
So, what happened there was
Paul was very learned.
And he quoted many
Epicurean dictum. He knew what the
philosopher spoke. And he would use
that.
Let me give you a modern example. I know
exactly what the evolutionists say
because I studied it at university for
years and years and years.
So, that doesn't become my reality now,
but it becomes my my argument as to why
I don't believe it.
So, he's quoting an Epicurean dictum
that you're speaking in the spirit and,
you know,
you don't know. He's talking about what
happened in pagan temples.
How the people communicated.
Uh what their relationship was with God
and they were all led by by the
spiritualistic
influence.
There wasn't a clear defined basis onto
which you can build your house. There's
no foundation. It's all airy-fairy
hanging in the air. Whatever the spirit
tells you, that becomes your reality.
And that spirit constantly contradicts
the word of God. If you love me, keep my
commandments. The first thing they will
say is the commandments are gone.
Jesus says
I've not come to abolish the law. Not
one jot or one tittle will disappear
from the law.
And they will quote to Romans chapter 3
and read the whole thing leave the last
verse out.
Because the last verse totally
contradicts their whole philosophy. So,
the spirit becomes the norm. Your
feeling becomes the norm and therefore
if I have the same spirit if I have the
same phenomenon, then I am your brother.
So, let's say in a spiritualistic
meeting in another religion, let's take
Hinduism for example.
They have the same manifestations, then
we must be brothers.
Then this these must be two paths to the
same reality. Because the spirit is
working in the same It's working in the
same way.
But the Bible says nobody comes to the
Father except by Jesus, except by the
Son.
So, how can I have relations with
entities or religious systems that deny
the divinity of the Son or deny the
atonement just because the spiritual
manifestation is the same?
Can you see how Christianity and Eastern
mysticism have commingled?
Have you Have you watched television?
Isn't that what's going on 24/7?
Why?
Because the foundation has been removed
and the the feeling and the euphoria
that is what has taken the place of the
reality.
See, the I I
have a lot of sympathy for people that
speak in tongues.
Because I understand because I've been
in charismatic church for most of my
life and family
also sold in those churches.
But the problem is that they believe
that once you can speak in that
gibberish
that you've received the Holy Spirit.
The gift of the Holy Spirit.
And that and if you haven't received it
yet, if you can't cannot do that yet
then they are praying for you and hope
that that will manifest with you.
So, once you've
received this so-called gift and you can
speak it, you really believe
that this is from God. Yes. And the
interesting thing is Paul very clearly
states that there are different gifts
and not everybody gets the same gift.
But by requiring that everybody gets
this particular gift, you are actually
contradicting scripture.
And they will tell you to start speaking
in tongues even if you don't feel it.
Just start babbling and it will happen.
>> Yeah. And that is coercion.
That is that in itself is spiritualism
because coercion is a form of
spiritualism. Very important. Coercion
is a form of spiritualism.
Yes, trying to subject one man to
another man's mind. That's spiritualism.
That's what the devil does best. That's
what he did in Eden.
But then hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on again.
I'm I'm sorry.
But then would somebody charge us with
being coercive in regards to when we try
to speak the gospel in a certain type of
way?
Yep.
That's what Pope Francis said
we're not allowed to do any
proselytization.
All right. Now how how do you Do you
coerce someone when you preach the
gospel or you Are you putting the
information out there?
Must he do his own
He must do his own thinking.
So the only thing is like if we were to
say, "Well, you know my my friends, you
know, I'm I'm telling you because I love
you and if you do not accept this
this this God that died to save us, you
will you know, you will die an eternal
death and separate yourselves." Like
this could be a form or somebody may
think it could be a form of coercion.
If you understand what I'm saying like
how does that How do we
separate ourselves from that? True
coercion doesn't take no no for an
answer.
>> Yeah.
And
there's no choice.
The choice [clears throat] is taken away
from you.
Whereas whereas convicting someone or
preaching to someone never ever negates
the personal choice.
Thank you for clearing that up. Thank
you. That's powerful. That that was that
was that's powerful. That's clear. Yeah,
that's that's pretty clear. I'm I'm
good.
So Pastor, on the subject of tongues, so
one of the things we do, we have um
a Facebook group where like every
Saturday we have for our members we we
have discussion where people can just
come ask random questions. There was a
question that came up about tongues this
past week and I wanted to know how you
interpret 1 Corinthians 14 particularly
um
verse 12
and 13. Actually more of verse 13.
Wherefore let him that speaketh in an
unknown tongue pray that he may
interpret. So there was a lot of
confusion on this verse. I think one of
the views was, "Hey, a person is able to
speak in an unknown tongue but they're
not able to interpret it or
and so they should pray that they can
interpret it so that they could share
the the message
and it caused a lot of confusion among
some of our our friends here. So All
right. How do you understand what does
this mean point?
>> The first thing you must notice when you
put up that verse is that the word
unknown was in cursive.
That means it's not in the original.
So you can leave the word unknown out
and say the person that speaks in a
tongue.
Now tongue has been identified in Acts
chapter 2 as to exactly what it is, a
known language. Now let me give you an
example. If I'm in an in an American
audience
and I'm trying to show off that I have
more than one language under my belt
and I speak in German or in Afrikaans to
that audience, will they be edified?
No, they might be impressed that I can
speak these languages. Maybe I can speak
12 then I'll be able to speak Greek and
this and that and the other and impress
everyone with my you know, with my
skills in terms of languages.
No, if you if you are speaking to an
audience
and there is someone in the audience who
happens to let's say be a German and
he's struggling to understand what you
are saying in English and he puts up his
hand and he asks you a question in
German because he didn't understand
something. It would be appropriate for
me to give him that answer in German if
I'm capable of speaking that language.
But to leave it there would be
inappropriate because I would have to
interpret it for the other people in the
audience so that they can know what I
have said.
So Paul goes further. He says if someone
comes in and he hears you all praying
and speaking in your different languages
that you have received, will he not say
that you are mad?
It says that just a little bit further
on in the same chapter. Oh yeah. So when
I speak, I will speak so that people can
understand. I won't boast with my
language and if I do use my language for
whatever reason as I've given an
example,
then I need to interpret.
Now let's say somebody asks a question
and he asks a question in Greek and he
says he doesn't understand my English so
well. Then I have another problem
because I don't speak Greek.
Then I would have to ask is there a
Greek-speaking person in this audience
who can please translate and interpret
what this person has said so that we can
all be edified by the question. That's
what Paul was talking about.
He is there somebody that can help the
people [clears throat] to understand
what is being said.
>> Yes, because the idea is you have to
speak about the gospel. The aim of
speaking in tongues is to communicate
the truth to someone else.
Amen. And the truth is always bound up
in Jesus. It's bound up in the word and
it's bound up in the commandments. And
if it's not in that, it's from the
devil.
Mhm. Amen. So just to clarify because
there there is a lot of
questions like
on the day of Pentecost Mhm.
they were not able naturally to speak
those languages and so here's the the
question that I had and maybe some
others might have this question. Were
Like for example, I speak English. Was I
if I was there on the day of Pentecost
and I was one of the disciples, was I
speaking English but they're hearing it
in their own language or was I just
given the ability to speak those 15
languages that were given on Pentecost?
What what is that authentic Holy Spirit
tongues that happened? All right. The
original one was
that you could actually speak the
language
and you retained the ability to speak
the language because you were busy with
certain language groups that you were
not familiar with before and you were
able to communicate. There is another
way in which it happened
that you are speaking your language
but the hearer is hearing it in his or
her language.
>> Got the gift of hearing. So they have a
gift of hearing. Amen. Amen. And I
actually had an experience like that
myself, not not directly
but people were asking why
they were listening to one of the DVDs
and they said they didn't know that I
was speaking that particular language,
whatever it was. Let's say Swahili. I
can't remember exactly which one it was.
And I'd never done anything in Swahili
whatsoever or similar.
So obviously these people were hearing
something in a language that they were
familiar with even though I was not on
the DVD speaking that language.
So you have some modern forms of this. I
I have another example.
Uh there was a lecturer at one of our
colleges here in South Africa
and he was preaching in Afrikaans.
And there was a Portuguese lady in the
audience that heard his sermon in
Portuguese
and was convicted
by the sermon but she was totally
incapable of even speaking one word in
Afrikaans.
Now that preacher and that lady actually
got together and eventually they were
married.
So
>> [laughter]
>> and and I knew them personally so it's
not a hearsay story. I heard it out of
the horse's mouth. So there was a modern
day phenomenon where the one was
speaking in one language and the other
one was hearing it in another language.
And it it didn't continue like that for
the rest of their relationship. Of
course she understood a little bit of
English but he wasn't speaking English.
He was speaking Afrikaans of which she
had no knowledge.
And eventually, you know, the gospel was
communicated more with hands and feet
and English and the little bit that they
understood and
that phenomenon ceased but in the
original with the disciples once they
had the language, they retained it.
Mhm.
So so is it
so can someone like for example like
let's say you know, at times I do speak
in in French-speaking churches and other
things as well.
Is that a Is that an okay prayer to pray
that if I speak in my regular language
that they can hear in their in in their
own language or in French or or
something I should be praying like which
I guess which one should should
something that we be covered in is it
either or as far as I'm speaking in
their language or they could just hear
in their own. If you're going to speak
their language, then fine. If you can't,
then you need an interpreter. Yeah, it's
always that's why most of the times it's
nice I won't say it's a gift then, but
if you if you it is a gift. If you ask,
listen, I'm going to preach in English.
Is there anybody that can just translate
for this person? That's also a gift in
of tongues.
To interpret what you being what you're
saying to edify the person that's going
to listen to it in
in the translated version.
>> I don't know whether you've had any of
these experiences in your ministry.
I've had very few of them, but I I did
have a few that were very
[clears throat] compelling.
What I told you just now was what I had
heard from the actual people involved.
But
I was giving a lecture series in a town
in South Africa
and I was also speaking in in Afrikaans.
And someone had a dream
that they were to attend these lectures.
And in the dream they [clears throat]
actually saw the speaker which happened
to be me in that particular occasion.
And they saw the building and they saw
the street.
But they didn't get an address.
And so this particular person was so
you know convinced that he had to go and
look for this the dream was really real
to him.
And so he he rented a taxi
and had the taxi drive up and down the
the streets in this particular town
until he saw the building that he'd seen
in his dream. And he walked in and there
I was speaking and I was speaking in
Afrikaans and he didn't speak a word of
Afrikaans.
He couldn't understand one single word.
So now what the question is why did he
have a dream and what was he there for?
And the interesting thing is
I was standing in the front and I saw
him walk in.
And you might find this interesting. I'm
going to throw it in. Normally I try and
avoid this this type of topic.
But
it was one of those times just after the
apartheid era.
You understand what I'm saying?
So there was still a lot there was still
a lot of confusion as to how the various
races should co-mingle and all of that
sort of thing.
And because I was speaking in Afrikaans,
I had a 100% white audience.
And the person who walked in was a black
man.
And he didn't speak one word of
Afrikaans. Now this is very odd, isn't
it? That he should have a dream that he
should have to come to this particular
meeting.
And I happened to see him
why I reacted is because here walks a
black man into this white audience. This
is just post-apartheid.
This is just in that interim period.
This is a very odd thing to happen under
those circumstances.
So I automatically reacted by walking to
him and welcoming him
and asking him, you know,
are you are you okay with Afrikaans or
what have you? And he said he didn't
understand a word of Afrikaans. So I
arranged an interpreter for him
to go and sit with him
and interpret for him. So that was my my
personal experience and he told me why
he was there and how he got there and he
didn't know I was there either.
And
I just found this very fascinating. So
there's one of those examples where
language and interpretation and all of
these things all came together
in one modern day experience, yeah.
That's pretty awesome.
Okay.
Any questions? Yeah, okay. No, I think
that answers all the the tongues
questions that I have. Um
yeah. Yeah. So wait.
Wait, wait, wait. So then the 1
Corinthians 14 then is not necessarily
speaking about when someone gives the
supernatural gift of tongues. It's
talking about if you actually have the
ability to speak other languages, it's
better to speak Correct.
>> languages that they understand rather
than interpret it. Of course.
>> Yeah. Paul was also aware that the
the the Sibylline priests priestesses in
the pagan temples spoke in
unrecognizable tongues. So that
phenomenon is sort of mingled in there
and thrown in as well.
So
he makes it quite clear if if I'm
speaking someone that no one
understands, I'd rather speak one word
with my understanding than a thousand
words that mean nothing to anyone else.
So that also becomes very clear in that
chapter. So if you look at the contrasts
of what what he is addressing and how it
should be you can pick it up with the
word but. This is what you are doing
but
and the interesting point is
all of it boils down to a
self-aggrandizement.
I have this gift.
I have this special relationship with
God. Now Martin, you were in the
charismatic movement. That's what you
feel, right? Yep. You have this special
gift. That's why chapter 14 is preceded
by the chapter of love and agape.
Love is not self-seeking.
It doesn't seek its own. It tries to
edify the other person. It is not
selfish.
Whereas everything that was practiced in
1 Corinthians 14 was selfishness.
And if you go through the entire chapter
then you will see that Paul is
constantly addressing that which they
are doing which is wrong.
And he's saying, I hear that there are
contentions amongst you. I hear that
some people, you know, are fornicating
amongst you. I hear that you are doing
this wrong. It's not a book of
commendation. No. It's a contrast.
opposite. So why should one chapter now
jump out and be the be-all and be-all of
commendation
when the whole tenor of the book is
condemnation?
Pastor, forgive me cuz I want to make
sure that this
conversation about the state of the I'm
sorry, about tongues is just no
questions left. Last question. Do it. Do
it. Last question.
How do we interpret verse 18 when Paul
says, I thank my God I speak with
tongues more than you all? Yes, Paul
>> saying I thank my God that he's given me
the gift more than you or that I have
the ability to speak more languages or
what?
>> God has given me numerous languages that
I can communicate because I have been
called as the apostle to the Gentiles.
>> Gentiles, yeah. Therefore I go from one
country to the other. I mean he even
went to Spain. What did he speak there?
He must have spoken Spanish. There
wasn't Google Translate then. Now
imagine
imagine [laughter] an Israelite speaking
Spanish. It's unheard of.
Or he spoke Italian.
Or he spoke Greek or he spoke all of
that. Now in his in his learned state he
obviously knew Greek.
But when he came into
the contact with the the languages like
spoken in Syria, for example and the
first church was in Antioch that is
Syria.
So obviously they were speaking the
Syrian language and they were speaking
the the languages that the Turks are
speaking because he was preaching in the
cities of Asia Minor and he was speaking
in Italian and he was speaking in
Spanish and uh
uh he communicated with the British.
Maybe he was speaking Keltish, you know.
He had gifts of tongues more than anyone
else.
Right.
Just a
>> Amen. Thank you. Just wanted to say
because there's a there's a little bit
of confusion sometimes
about speaking in tongues and
prophesying because it mentions the both
of them the whole time in the chapter
and especially chapter 14.
Correct. Just explain that portion. All
right. What does it mean to prophesy?
Now to prophesy can mean to receive
visions like a prophet.
But in the context in which it was used
there, it means preaching the gospel.
>> Yeah.
So
it's great that you all speak in
tongues.
But you know what?
Prophesy.
Use your gift to communicate the gospel.
And when you are speaking with your own
brethren, don't don't don't be puffed up
because that's one of the issues. You
are puffed up Because you can speak
other languages.
>> can do all of these things now. Yeah.
It's very easy to get puffed up in this
religion, you know. That's why God
always gives us a bunks on the bean that
we can come back to reality.
>> Oh yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Reality check. Oh yes.
So
Jason, are you
done with the All right. I'm done with
all my questions, but Azul's
question because I think this this is
based on chapter 13. He says, "Though I
speak with the tongues of men and of
angels." Now, I have understanding of
this, but since it was a question that
came up,
what does he mean? It like some people
will interpret this and say, "Oh, but
there is a language that only God
understands or that only the angels
understand."
But I don't But I don't understand it,
but I can speak it, you know. I think
that's where they're coming from. All
right. Do it. Angels speak English.
I believe they can. Of course they can
speak English. All right.
All right. Here's another question. Did
angels speak English before the Tower of
Babel?
I believe so.
I'm not sure. I don't know. I don't
think so. Absolutely not. English didn't
exist. It didn't exist.
None of the languages existed until the
Tower of Babel where God confused the
languages.
So, obviously the angels have a
language, right?
And that is not a language that we
speak.
Do you think Adam and Eve could speak
that language?
Probably. Probably yes because they were
communicating with angels probably in an
angelic language.
And
so,
will we be able to speak to angels in
their language? Well,
I believe that the confusion of tongues
that came about at the Tower of Babel
is a temporary issue
that was to avoid the the unity of
humanity in evil.
So, that you would constantly be, you
know, dependent upon God
because of constant
conflict between different language
groups like we have in the world to this
very day.
But when when God creates a new world
and new heaven and a new earth, we will
receive another language.
And all of the languages I mean there
are people that love to say, you know,
Polish is the is the language of heaven
because it's about the size of of the
New Jerusalem, etc. etc.
All of the languages are going to go
because our languages are so polluted
with evil and evil nuances.
And
in and
in and in those and swearing and and
false evil puns and just loaded with
filth that those languages are all going
to disappear and we will have a bright,
clean, angelic language.
Amen.
Amen. Amen. I I have a I have a
question. I have a I have a question.
Um you know that we shift back to the
spiritualism through the scriptures.
What is the How does Simon Magus I was
here about this guy, right? I think he
spoke to him spoke about him on lectures
before. Yes. What's the What's the
effects of Simon Magus as far as on
spiritualism? As far as I know he's Acts
chapter 8. I know he came around that
time. What's his effect? He wanted to
buy the gifts of the spirit, remember?
Now,
uh
Peter rebuked him very very sternly
because he thought he could buy the
gifts of the spirit. So, why did he want
to buy the gifts of the spirit? Because
he wanted to use them to further his
interests and his influence.
And
when that did not materialize, if you go
to the writings of Freemasonry,
then you will you will read even in in,
you know, Albert Pike's writings, for
example,
that Simon Magus became the sorcerer to
the Emperor Nero.
So, he became the Let's call him the
spiritual adviser
of the Emperor Nero. Do we have
spiritual advisers to the current
emperors in this world?
Uh etc. Let's Constantine.
>> [laughter]
>> It's Constantine.
Oh, Cyrus the Great.
Okay. Let's leave it at that. So, he
became the spiritual adviser.
And his name was Simon.
And they were called the
Petras. So, you could actually call them
the Peters.
So, they became the Simon Peter, the
spiritual adviser to the emperor. And
that is where church and state started
mingling with each other.
And
Simon Magus is the one that
wanted these gifts of the spirit
in order to communicate his version of
the gospel.
Do we have someone who has a particular
version of the gospel that elevates him
rather than Christ? That makes him
infallible. That makes him the the
mediator. And that without this priest
in your in your toolbox, you will not be
able to have the communication with God
that you're supposed to have. So, this
is an elevation of man
and compared with the elevation of
Christ.
He must increase. I must decrease. Not
in that religion.
They must increase. Everybody else must
decrease. They must be acknowledged as
the spiritual
uh moral leaders of the world.
And it's interesting that the papacy
actually did exactly that during Easter.
When the Pope washed the feet of 12
priests,
but there was no reciprocal washing of
his own feet.
In other words, he was
He was emulating what Christ was doing.
He was taking the position of Christ.
And then he carried the cross around the
stations of the cross demonstrating that
he is emulating what Christ did. And
then there's an an a statement in the
article
that they wrote about this where they
state that he is the moral leader of the
world.
Now, that is very much what Simon Magus
wanted to be.
And
we are told
that the scriptures are to give us our
moral base based on the 10 Commandments.
Blessed are they that keep the
commandments that they may have a right
to the tree of life.
So, yes, the this element of being
puffed up, of elevating yourself,
and you can elevate yourself with a
sense of false humility,
uh but nevertheless, you want to receive
the accolades of the world and the
obedience of the world,
then then you are in the category of
Simon Magus.
It's a false Simon Petra, the false
Simon Peter. So, the Simon Peter that
that talking about is not the disciple,
but Simon Magus.
That's so important. And And just
another I just wanted to mention on what
you mentioned where he walked with the
cross now.
And it was actually such a slap in the
face of
of God
because he did it in the Colosseum.
That's amazing. That's where all the
tortures took place.
>> Of the Christians. Yeah. And so, it was
just Yeah, it's horrific. The the like
you said, it's under the garb of
humility.
You see, Now, so
Now, you you
>> you going? You you you have
had a certain facial expression when I
said that the washing of the feet was
not reciprocal.
You know, the Bible is very clear that
we must wash each other's feet.
It's not that the pastor goes round and
washes everybody's feet in the
congregation. His feet are just as
filthy as everybody else's.
By leaving himself out of that equation,
he's elevating himself to the position
of Christ. In other words, he's saying
he's another Christ. That's antichrist.
>> [laughter]
>> Mercy.
My goodness.
So, he was the Pope before the Pope.
Apparently. Yes, [clears throat]
correct. So, the Yeah. That's
spiritualism. And that spiritualism is
part of what Catholicism is about and
it's steeped in mysticism.
If you walk into a Catholic uh cathedral
and there's a mass going on,
the voices that are there, you know, you
had in the old days you had
uh
Let's not go too deeply into this, but
you know, the little boys that sang and
uh
if they had beautiful voices, they
castrated them so they were called
castratos so that they would not lose
their voices because this this beautiful
ringing sound in this cathedral wall and
the organ and the music, they were all
designed to create a particular
ambiance. In other words, to put you
into an altered state of consciousness.
Hypnotism. It is a a technique
of getting your mind to be so
euphoriated
that you you cannot distinguish between
right and wrong anymore. You lose your
discernment. Inhibition.
Wow.
That easy.
That easy, yes. That's That's what you
do in a movie. Well, that's exactly what
Who designed movies? Yeah. It was the
Jesuits.
The one who came up with the idea of
movies was a Jesuit by the name of Kino.
Now, the interesting thing is in the
German language, Kino is a bioscope.
That's where you go to the theater to
watch. That's the name that they use.
They call it Kino cuz it comes from a
Jesuit. He designed it in order to
manipulate your mind.
It already started with the Greeks and
all of them when they had the plays.
Yes, the plays.
They couldn't get certain things for
accepted in society, so they started
with plays.
And then whatever they wanted to get
infiltrated into society.
>> the interesting thing is now let's go a
little bit deeper. Once you start
introducing something into a a showcase,
into a play,
then certain things are permissible
which otherwise would not be
permissible.
So, if you take a movie, it has become
not only permissible, it has become the
norm to wear as little as possible or
absolutely nothing.
Now, obviously, once your mind is
focused on that absolutely nothing that
this particular person is wearing,
then you can obliquely, while you're
focusing on that, put other thoughts
into your mind.
And that is that is subliminal
preaching. Yeah. Now, you can do the
same with sport.
So, in the old days when the ladies did
sport, they had a particular attire, but
the Greeks took it down to complete
nakedness. We today are as close as you
can possibly get to nakedness, so that
some people are not really concerned of
how fast this individual is running, but
rather looking at the performance from
another angle.
And then again,
>> Mercy.
>> [clears throat]
>> you can do the same thing in a church
setting, you can do the same thing in a
theater, and it is the way to manipulate
your mind.
Music.
>> blowing. I mean, I don't know if you
guys ever saw some of the Little Light
Studios productions that they've had on
Hollywood. Of course. And that shows you
exactly when your mind it just has to
take your mind to an alpha state, and
you are to anything that's being put
towards you. All right, so your visual
experience that you are having
uh opens the channel for subliminal
implants. You can do the same with
eating and drinking.
You can do the same with alcohol. You
can do the same with stimulating foods.
Yeah, we don't have to go into all the
details. Now, we're going, you know,
into your very lifestyle. So, this is a
very holistic approach to good and evil.
Because you can use any one of those in
order to introduce that altered state of
consciousness. And if you go into the
New Age movement,
and you you look at how these channels
are channeling spirit entities,
very often, if not all the time, drugs
play a role.
It might start with a glass of wine, but
it'll end with hard drugs.
And all of these come together.
And
the music in itself then also becomes a
drug. And Martin, Yeah.
>> you speak from personal experience that
you could use the drug, but later you
didn't even need it, you just needed the
music. Tell them about that.
>> I used to
be in the rave scene.
You know, underground trance and rave
music and that old scene.
And like you said, in the beginning you
you used drugs to give you an
wonderful experience and all of this,
but eventually,
after years,
I didn't need any of that. I could just
hear the listen to the music. And that
will give you enough energy. I didn't
even have to drink alcohol. We drank
water.
Dra Dance right through the night
because your you trained your body
through all of those things to let them
release the
serotonin and the dopamine and all of
that just by the music that you listen
to.
So, the the spiritualistic world covers
such an array of phenomena.
Every single one of your senses, and if
you can enhance those senses with
something,
whatever that something is, it opens a
channel.
It can be something like a sugary drink,
Mhm. which gives you a hypoglycemic
reaction, which opens a channel for
something to be implanted in your mind.
Wow.
And Pastor, you know, what you're
telling me, one of the first sermons I
heard when I was coming into the into
the church. And by the way, I grew up
atheist, so I came in
I came in through messages like these.
Atheists make good Adventists.
Say that again? I said atheists make
good Adventists just by contrast.
>> [laughter]
>> Like Catholics, too. Catholics make good
Adventists.
It's cuz I would not accept anything
unless it was it was proven and it made
sense. And so, Bible prophecy was that
thing for me. But one of the first
things I heard was this message from
Pastor Myers called I think it was
called Escape the Black Hole. Uh-huh.
And he started by saying, "Do you know
anybody who struggles with sorcery?"
Right? Let me hear that again. And
nobody raised their hand, but then he
read this verse and he says, um
"For thy merchants were the great men of
the earth, for by thy sorceries were all
nations deceived." And then he's saying
that the Bible is saying sorcery is not
just affecting a few people, it's
affecting the whole world. Absolutely.
>> and then he and then he broke it down.
Sorcery is basically anything that
medicates the mind like a drug. Anything
that medicates the mind so that it
doesn't do the the will of God. That
word sorcery um
you know, it basically goes into this
whole thing of medication or pharmacy,
right? Pharmakeia.
And it's like what you're saying it's
like this is really a tool of Satan to
like put so many things in front of us
that medicates our mind. And it's like
when you're talking about movie going,
it makes adultery normal. Yes.
>> It makes killing normal. It makes sin
normal. Have you noticed that the
sorcery in that verse is linked to
merchants? Mhm.
Now, a merchant is someone who wants to
sell you something.
Now, what is the means that is used by
the world to induce you to buy
something? Obviously, it's the
advertising world.
And the advertisements that are placed
up there
have subliminals in them.
And those subliminals work below your
level of consciousness.
And it creates a craving for something.
Now, that craving can be based on any
one of your senses. It can be
a craving for food.
It can be a craving for drink. It can be
a craving for a vice like drinking
alcohol or smoking or taking drugs. It
can be a craving for sexuality.
Now,
how much of the advertising world uses
sexuality
in order to grab your attention?
I mean,
90% Will they will they use a male in
order to entice you or will they use a
a sultry lady in order to get your
attention?
>> Car advertisements.
>> Yes. What does a car got to do with the
lady sitting on a bonnet?
>> For example.
For example.
>> [laughter]
>> Mercy. So, sorcery
is part and parcel of the advertising
world.
It is to charm you. That's sorcery. To
cast a spell upon you. To make you think
the way they want you to think, to crave
things that they want you to crave. So,
the merchants are using this. Now, if
you don't guard the avenues of your mind
through what you drink, what you eat,
that can elevate what's getting put into
your mind. Because if you drink a
caffeinated drink that puts your that
takes away 40% of the oxygen to your
brain,
I'm I'm sorry, what?
A caffeinated drink.
>> Repeat that again.
If you use a caffeinated drink, and
they've proven that if through MRI MRI
scans that if you drink one cup of
coffee,
it
cuts off the oxygen to your brain with
40%.
So, you're so So, if you have not got
full capacity of your brain, how easy is
it for a subliminal advertisement
through these merchants to get you?
Very easy.
I mean, I don't know whether you've seen
any of those shows where
uh people pre-pro- program you to think
in a particular way,
and then in an interview they ask you to
draw a picture or something, and you do
exactly what they pre-programmed you to
do in the first place.
That's the power of subliminal
implantation.
And Satan is the master of this. Now,
you know, I I read recently about
quantum oscillation.
Now, that's the [clears throat] latest
uh form of physics where two subatomic
particles are closely associated with
the other, and the other one will have a
response to any action taken by the
other one, even if they're separated by
light-years of distance, and the the
action is instantaneous.
Now, uh examples of that, let me give
you a classic example from my knowledge
of my own family.
My mother was one of twins.
And my mother during the war was living
in South Africa,
and her twin sister was living in
war-ravaged Germany.
And when her twin sister went into
labor,
my mother in South Africa went into a
form of labor,
and thereby she knew that her twin
sister was in labor.
Now, that is this particle communication
where the one feels the
you know, the the feelings of the other
one. And sometimes you have this feeling
that something is wrong with someone,
and you feel urged to contact them.
This reciprocal thing. Now, if if this
is happening in the real world, and God
is so keyed into his creation that he
can
can read everyone's thoughts and
feelings to a point that we cannot even
understand,
and the devil has studied the science of
the mind very very closely.
How much can he put into your mind and
implant into your thinking so that you
actually start doing his will rather
than the will of the Father?
So, we have to be very guarded and very
grounded in scripture, and we must be
very clear that I will not be moved
by a preacher that says, for example,
"Now, everybody sit back in your chairs,
stretch out your legs, take a deep
breath, empty your minds." And then the
music starts playing, "Run."
Because he's busy with the devil's work.
Uh
if he's not preaching the word,
but he is implanting a reaction in your
mind, then run.
And
it's also I just wanted to mention
another form of this is also
the gaming world.
Because that's at this stage bigger if
I'm not mistaken than movies and music
put together.
It's a very very it it makes you
desensitizes you. You mentioned earlier
about
blasphemy and all of this that's
desensitizing.
>> terrible things that are happening with
uh you know, murders of
senseless murders and and uh abductions
and the terrible things that are
happening to to children and to to girls
in particular, and all of these things
you will find that you are
pre-programmed to start thinking like
this once you get into that kind of
world. And also the spirit of prophecy
is very clear. She warns very clearly
about even novels. In her day it was
novels. Stay away from infidel
writings. All right. So, that's
spiritism. So, where do you want to find
spiritism?
You will find spiritism interwoven into
every fabric of life. There you go.
Everything.
And you don't even know it. You don't
even recognize it.
You know, Mr. I
>> [clears throat]
>> This This the generation born in the
2000s, that I think that's called Gen Z.
That's what they call them. Yes.
>> I know I know many of them. They're
really into the gaming world, and going
to bed at like 7:00 in the morning is
normal for a lot of them.
It's like they could easily stay up all
night, headphones on, gaming with their
friends. And when they're done gaming,
they go on like Netflix or whatever it's
called, and watch series upon series of
shows, and it's like It's drugs. It's a
drug.
All right. Now, let me let me go a
little bit further than that.
In other words, the entire generation
has been schooled in a particular
sensual type of experiential
existence. Would you agree with that?
And now, they are seeking for a
spiritual aspect. And where they moving
to?
And you will find that the media is
telling us and the news is telling us
that they are
are gravitating towards Catholicism.
>> Yeah. Because that same mystical element
feeds that which they have become
accustomed to in their daily experience.
>> charismatic churches as well.
>> And the charismatic, they are being
filled, whereas a rational words-based
religion is something that doesn't
satisfy that craving. It's boring.
>> When I came into and I we
studied and went to the Seventh-day
Adventist Church for the first time,
I remember the shock that we got when in
the music, because I said,
"The sermon was okay. I could live with
it, but this music, there's something
has to be done about it."
And today,
I don't want to hear anything else than
hymns.
Because you have you come from a world I
mean, it's like listening If you listen
to normal
radio
during the week, what music are they
playing? So, here you get to church, and
they you sing a hymn, then
But if you don't listen to that nonsense
during the week, and you cut it off from
yourself, and you then God you you
uh
What is it?
The word? But you're clearing yourself
of all the
clogging that there is.
>> Toxic. Yeah, the toxic. Yeah, you see,
music is a form of prayer.
Yeah, that's
>> And prayer is speaking to God as with a
friend.
So, do you speak with a to a friend by
repeating phrases over and over and over
even in music lyrics? I mean, if you try
that with your wife, try to communicate
something to her, she will tell you that
you've gone insane.
But once you do it in a church setting,
it seems to be perfectly fine.
So, if music is a form of prayer, then
the whole package is a form of prayer.
And it must make sense, because you're
communicating with God.
That's why I also love hymns. I mean, my
favorite hymns are
for example, um
Lead me to Calvary.
>> Lead me to Calvary or
and And can it be?
>> And can it be? Because they they are so
so beautiful or even How Great Thou Art.
And uh the Jesuits say they they cannot
sing verse three because it talks about
the atonement and that Christ died for
you, and they don't agree with it
theology. That's why I want to sing it
all the louder, because they don't agree
with it, and I really want to rub it in
by shouting it from the rooftops. Amen.
[laughter]
Amen. You know, I I don't think I've
ever understood before today,
especially I think that one statement to
me encapsulated everything that I was
kind of looking for as far as everything
can be interwoven with spiritualism,
which is scary, which almost now makes
the the the statement that she made that
much more important now.
Because I never considered I I
I've never made the connection between
the gaming and the movies and I mean,
yes, I know they have some sort of
demonic um movies that's a little more
blatant, but even just regular the the
form of storytelling through cinema,
that's a form of spiritualism. Yes.
Right?
For sure. And
like you mentioned that like that that
you brought up of Revelation that
we must I I I also just realize when you
were mentioning it how powerful that is
the pharmacare that sorceries Yeah. And
now they use it and the merchants use it
and now just to bring it back I just
want to mention it again. So if you are
putting stuff in your body that can put
you in the state that where you are
susceptible to these things
all these things are bombarded to you on
a daily basis when you drive around
where you what wherever you go.
So we have to be very careful.
When you think about the principle
behind a lot of video games for example
the killing games is like you die and
you come back to life. Or you kill a
person and that person comes back to
life. It's like it really prepares your
mind to think that hey immortality it's
possible that you can live forever and
ever and ever also without God.
What do these adverts do and what do the
movies do?
They create in you a craving
for a different kind of world
where you are
basically above the mundane things that
are happening in the world. For example
if you take ecstasy
you have this euphoric feeling that you
can love better than others love that
your love is so much deeper that your
connection with your fellow human being
is on a different level. And it creates
this craving
to have that situation rather than the
situation that you are in. So you are
constantly unhappy because your husband
or your girlfriend is not providing what
you feel that you should be getting. So
you have this constant hope for a better
something for this knight in shining
armor is going to throw his clothes
across the puddle
and [clears throat] it creates this
sense of I'm not happy with my
situation.
Therefore you can never be happy. You're
always seeking.
>> And you're always seeking seeking a
higher reality and if you start doing
that in your religion
then you are divorcing yourself from the
from the foundation and you are seeking
this higher plane.
Because when I listen to
to these spiritualistic demons that in
the past
were channeled and they would say you
know you are so much more intelligent
than my other subjects. Therefore with
you I can communicate on a different
level and you get sucked into this
experience and you think that you are
something that you are not. Or if you
are somebody that's a little bit you
don't you're not you don't have a little
bit of a self problem.
>> Yes.
You don't feel you're worthy and this
one is elevating you the whole time. So
oh well. And and this is a it's a sense
of non-reality.
So what we basically need to to get to
grips with is that we are living in a
real world
and that
these expectations that are created by
these subliminal implants
that make you unhappy. I believe they
lead to divorces. They lead to
separation of people. They lead to
separation of siblings. They lead to
separation between children and parents
and the whole of society is fractured.
And that is exactly the terrain in which
the devil can flourish.
The sad portion oh sorry.
Go ahead pastor. No go ahead elder elder
Warner. I'll go ahead you. I just wanted
to say that the the sad thing is that
the
picture that a movie sketches of a real
man or real woman is so much divorced
from what the Bible actually wants that
person to be. Yes.
You mean to tell me you're a miserable
sod in actual fact. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> This is this is this is mind-blowing
because
can I just show you something? I I I
like words right and I just
etymology online is basically like where
do words begin or come from right?
Entertainment to keep up maintain or to
keep someone in a certain frame of mind.
There you go. Perfect.
That's keep someone in a certain
and the word tain the detain part right
or the men or something like that like
to hold. So the whole idea of
entertainment is to keep you in a
certain frame of mind. We really need to
be careful what we entertain ourselves
with because
like Satan is after the mind. And when
do you usually want to do
watch a movie or even play a game of
that is when you want to relax. You want
to take it easy because you've had so
much hard work and all of this.
Then you get sucked right into
the the pit of all of the nonsense.
It's very hard. It's actually
a battle with self.
And I experience it in my own life
and therefore I cannot lay any claim to
perfection. Not at all. But I I try and
war against it. I'm not saying I'm
always successful.
But
at least I try to stay away from
that which is visually disturbing
or visually enticing and stay with
simple things that
which which basically means I'm cut off
from the modern world and have to if I
look at something look at something
that's almost 100 years old
order not to be
swept away
and you know like old programs that
still had some virtue in them and didn't
have the language or the
or the licentiousness in it.
And it's a tough world because you feel
like an like an odd man out. You don't
fit into society and it I can understand
that it's difficult. Oh for sure. So we
need to pray and we need to ask God
to help us to stick with reality
and not to be sucked into any one of
these forms of spiritualism.
Amen. I know Martin if you want to say
something go ahead. No I was just
remembering
and I'm not
saying people must watch movies but they
brought out a movie a while back which
was called Ready Player One
and it depicted a dis
yes it depicted a dystopian world
where
everybody is in this virtual reality.
Yes. Because the
real world is boring and it's a
nightmare. It's chaos.
And this is what exactly what you
described earlier what they tried to do
with music and with all of these things
it's an escape from reality.
Well all of these religious systems that
bring you onto a higher plane or promise
you a higher plane. They are forms of
spiritualism.
Now if you take
we'll probably get into trouble for
saying things like this but let's take
Scientology.
Scientology takes you through your
experiences in this life and even go so
far as to take you through experiences
in the so-called previous life
and then it will try to clear you of
your negative karma.
And once you have reached this clear
position you are on a higher plane than
anyone else and open to a communication
which is of a higher level and you
become a coach.
And once you become a coach then
[clears throat]
if you do that in in a normal Christian
situation where you have a coach that
coach is supposed to be obeyed
irrespective of your own conscience and
that is coercion and that is
spiritualism.
And that is what you have in in courses
even like the Alpha course
where you will have a coach and you will
try to reach consensus and in order to
reach consensus you must remove
everything from your vocabulary that
could go against that consensus.
So if you don't agree let's say on
Sabbath Sunday issue you never talk
about it. You only find points of
contact and concentrate on those
and that's exactly what the Pope said
that we must do. We may never
concentrate on doctrine because that
will separate
us but the Bible says take heed of the
doctrines. So now how do you want to
believe believe? The one who's coercing
you into a false sense of of unity
or do you want to listen to the Bible
which says you will never achieve it
that way therefore come out and be
separate. That's the bottom line.
Can I I I wanted to actually follow up
on what you had said before and I think
I need more information and more
understanding on it. What exactly is I
hear this term all the time and I think
Martin and Doc you you were mentioning
it. What is spiritual formation?
I hear that term so much but I I can't
say I have a full grasp on on what it
is. What is that? I guess
spiritual formation is based on Ignatian
spirituality.
Ignatius of Loyola of the Jesuits, he
came up with this idea.
And if you read Abignale's history of
Protestantism,
it'll contrast Martin Luther with
Ignatius Loyola. Martin Luther decided
that the word was going to be the basis
of his spirituality and his dogma.
So, he became word-based.
Uh,
"Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light unto my path." And they came up
with this term
uh, sola scriptura. If it's not in the
scriptures, it's not part of my reality.
Ignatius put the Bible aside and sought
direct contact with the spirit world in
order to be infused with a higher
knowledge.
And in order to achieve this, he
developed a number of exercises, again a
technique,
as to how to achieve this higher
consciousness.
And therefore, his main
tenant was visualization.
You are visualizing certain situations,
and this is exactly what
The Chosen does all the time.
They they portray pray visualized
scenarios.
A very common one would be where they
say, "Visualize that you are sitting at
the wedding in Cana."
And you are one in the audience and
you're seeing Mary running around, and
you see Jesus, and you see the
disciples.
And get a feel of it and get a feel
Imagine that you are tasting the wine
that was served before water was changed
into wine. And get a taste of that, so
you're using that sense. Imagine that
you're getting close to where Mary is
and you're touching her and you're
feeling the the texture of her skin, for
example.
And you smell the perfume that she is
using. And then use your sense of
hearing and try and contemplate or
visualize what she is saying.
And one of the things that she said is,
"Whatever he says, do."
So, Mary is the one that informs you and
says to you that this is what you must
do, what he said. So, you're actually
working now through Mary to Jesus. So,
you've actually broken the direct line
of connection and you're going through
another party now.
And then you actually pick up that glass
of wine and you drink the new one and
you must now imagine, you know, the
euphoria of that taste that you are
getting.
And then you actually start
communicating
with the entities that you are
associated with.
And this is exactly the same thing that
Freud did and that all of those
psychologists did. They developed these
techniques.
And then they started speaking to these
spirit entities. And Freud, for example,
spoke to a a spirit entity that he
identified as Elijah.
And Elijah was in the afterworld very
closely associated in his in his
visualizations with Salome.
Now, that is a contrast like you cannot
believe. Well, Salome is the one that
danced before the king and asked for the
head of John the Baptist. But
Elijah is the exact antithesis of that,
yet they are almost in a state of
matrimony in the afterlife. So, that's
yin yang.
Where good and evil have become fused
and the line of distinction is gone.
And that becomes your reality and your
spiritual adviser. Now, can you imagine
the jumble that can come out of that?
You can have the sensuality of this
sexually infused dance with the lady and
you can have the sternness of Elijah and
you mingle the two and they are married
to each other. Therefore, actually
anything goes and we're all good and
evil. You will have the knowledge of
good and evil. God never wanted us to
have the knowledge of evil.
He wanted us only to have the knowledge
of good. Evil has caused nothing but
pain and suffering.
So, this form of spirituality
seeks direct contact with the spiritual
spiritual world and it informs you as to
what truth is,
but it's not based on scripture.
It's extra-biblical. I remember that one
of the explanations one of the guys said
that they want to achieve an
extra-biblical explanation of certain
stories in the Bible also. Therefore,
you must never read your Bible,
according to them, as it stands.
But there's a statement in Ellen White
which says, "Read your Bible as it
stands.
And believe it and do it and none of you
will be lost."
So, it's the exact opposite,
but it's clothed in a garb of
spirituality.
Now, Ignatius actually went further and
he said that you must chastise yourself.
You must remind yourself of the
spirituality. So, if you take
organizations like Opus Dei, for
example, they wear uh,
bracelets and things which cause them
constant pain to remind them of this
thing or you have to experience the pain
that Jesus experienced. And the actor
who plays Jesus in The Chosen
actually said that. He said he asked God
for the crucifixion scene to give him a
measure of the pain and the suffering so
that he could almost be, in a sense,
mediating on behalf of humanity in terms
of that. That is taking something that
is the prerogative of Christ and
applying it to yourself. It is, in my
opinion, the highest form of blasphemy
that you can possibly get. But that is
where the spirituality of the world is
going.
And that is why you are using apps and
you are praying mantras and you are
praying rosaries and you are doing
certain things which give you merit with
God and they are absolutely
useless in terms of merit with God
because we have no merit.
I don't know if you know Christian
Bedal.
Well, I'll just say he had a very good
explanation on not everything that has
the label on Christian is holy.
Come on. And that is exactly what
spiritual formation does. It comes under
the
guise of Christian
spirituality or whatever, but it's not
holy.
So, what they are practicing is
unadulterated spiritual formation.
And beware because it is alive and well
even within the Adventist Church.
Yes,
so Pastor Pastor, that's exactly kind of
where I wanted to actually go cuz I know
we don't have that much time left cuz I
know we wanted to do two hour mark.
Um, so I'll try my best to,
you know, keep it quite to a minimum,
but
how does [snorts] that look now in the
Seventh-day Adventist Church cuz I know
some people say maybe the singing
possibly, especially the the repetitive
um, the repetitive verses. Is there is
there any other way that spiritual
formation is is kind of seen now in our
churches today, Seventh-day Adventist
Church? In in hundreds of ways. When we
emulate the techniques that are used in
the
in the evangelical world, where we have,
uh, you know, group studies of 12 around
one. Try and keep small groups together.
Get a spiritual adviser, a coach. And
then go it goes so far as to,
uh, if you have a problem, discuss it
with your coach.
And, uh, form these small groups where
you have this interaction and exchange.
This is almost like, uh, a confessional
where you
unburden yourself in terms of, you know,
your life problems.
And it is a technique to draw man away
from your direct communication with
Christ
because a new and better way has been
created. Through the veil, we come to
the throne
with with confidence because we have a
mediator.
But we've shifted that back to man.
And so, we become reliant on what the
pastor is preaching or what your group
is saying.
And the music that it is associated
with.
>> Even the lighting. And the lighting. You
have You have some churches within
within the realm that have changed into,
you know, they have strobe lights and
they have almost like bar settings and
they've introduced coffee bars to create
this un Yeah, so you can have a have a
nice cup of caffeine before you go in so
gone is the discernment and
>> gone and
all of that, it's all part of the
technique.
And
who was instrumental in bringing the
drugs into the world? Who brought
cocaine into the world? Who brought
cigarette smoking into the Western
world? Who brought booze and alcohol
into the world? Wasn't it the the Roman
Catholic Church and is particularly the
Jesuits and who then turned it into a
merchandise?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, wow.
Yeah, wow. The rabbit hole goes very
deep. It's very deep. Oh
my goodness. It does. Uh
and I I my my assumption would be that
these are the things especially as we as
we kind of march on toward the end of
time, these are the things that would
constitute spiritualism
or I guess or many forms to the time of
the mark of the beast. Correct. It will
just get
worse and worse. Now imagine
if the mark of the beast
comes together, if you look at the
typologies of the Bible with all kinds
of display and music and the most
beautiful
orchestras and the most wonderful
singers and singing together, we are the
world, we are the people and we are one
and we are going to move forward and you
have all of this euphoria of the music
and the display and the this and the
that and together and then you have
spiritualistic experiences and some
people are suddenly communicating with
some of the disciples
and they're they're making noises like
Jesus made and people are being healed
left, right, and center and some people
will see their dead children and are
they not going to be swept away? They're
going to be swept away by either the one
form or the other and nothing
can convince them otherwise. I've had so
many people tell me, I cannot deny my
experience. You have to deny your
experience if it's not biblical.
Pastor, what you just described remind
me so much of Daniel chapter 3 where
everybody was bowing down to the image,
but you don't but you think of the
surrounding context when you hear the
music bow down. Exactly. Exactly. And it
was all kinds of music. Every instrument
and so you'll have the rapper doing his
thing and you'll have the opera singer
doing his thing and you'll have
everything in between and there will be
some morsel for every taste in the
audience.
My goodness. And the experience will be
driving and not the word.
My goodness.
Pastor, can you come back again?
Yeah, we have a lot to talk about.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, yeah, we have a lot to talk about.
I'm sorry we are the bearers of such bad
news. I mean, this is not this is not
going to be super popular.
>> This is wonderful. You know what it is
because again, I've never and I mean
this sincerely, I've never looked at
spiritualism
into when we don't say anything. Like
because especially with the food that
you know, nobody likes to touch your
plate. Right? Don't touch your plate.
You can touch your
don't touch my plate.
And so when you even brought up the
whole spiritualism connection to the
food that we eat which kind of brought
me back to Exodus chapter 16 as far as
he had to almost kind of reset the mind
by giving them a certain diet and then
the commandments came not too long
after.
I'm like this is it all makes it all
makes sense to me, but especially a lot
of some of the Adventist churches, you
you you know, they don't like to serve
plant-based food. They like to serve,
you know, the flesh pots, you know, all
all those things. So and we don't
realize that by doing that we're
promoting spiritualism. Yes. People
think you are fanatic because you
mention these things.
Listen, if you if you understand what's
behind it, then
I don't care if they think I'm a
fanatic.
This is what God told us what we should
do to protect ourselves.
Have mercy.
Wow. I don't know if I speak this
message again, I might get stoned.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm going to use it though. Thank you
guys.
Any I guess we're we're wrapping up. I
know that that's man, I I wish I had a
few more hours.
But it would but I know they have things
to do.
Any more questions I guess before we we
wrap this thing up? I'm Jason.
I mean, there's tons of questions, but I
think I think we could probably save it
for another time. I think we got a lot
to digest here.
Yeah. Okay. There's none for me.
Yeah. I won't yeah, I'm I'm kind of full
right now.
That's the kind of full, but I got more
questions definitely for the next time
if they could be so kind to come back.
God bless you guys and your ministry.
>> [clears throat]
>> I think you're doing a great job.
Just keep going. That's that's our job.
Our job is to preach.
In other words,
that you prophesy Exactly.
>> about the truth. Yeah, yes. And
let's cut through the rabble and the
noise that is out there
and try and focus on what does the word
say?
And let's try and live the life that God
has prescribed for his people. He's
given us such beautiful examples.
He outlined exactly how the Levites
should be different from the others. He
outlined how Daniel and his friends were
to be different from the others. He's
given us such beautiful examples in the
Bible.
Those are things to emulate and not the
others. So
do those things and you will be called
friend of God.
Not because you're wonderful and you're
perfect, but because you believe him.
Because without faith it is impossible
to to please him.
And you yourself know, you told me you
were an atheist.
And what convinced you that you can have
faith? Prophecy convinced you. I was an
atheist. What convinced me? Prophecy
convinced me. And prophecy binds you to
the scriptures and to the word of God
and therefore that is the only safe
haven that I would suggest anyone to
choose.
Well said, doc. Amen.
So can I show people where to find you?
Yes.
I was going to say that like let's let's
give the people information on how to
find you, how to support you, you know,
slash donate if if they would like to.
Um
give us give us any information whatever
you want to share with the people. Well,
this is So am I actually I'm subscribed
to the correct page? Is this your page?
Yes, that's our YouTube page, correct.
Yeah. Yes. Yeah, so that's our YouTube
one and then if you go to our that
clashofminds.com,
that's right there on the screen, you
can just click on it and then it will
open our
website.
And
maybe I can just quickly while we're on
here just show you there's a very good
tool that we have. If you go if you
scroll down a little bit
and you go to that WhatsApp Prof one,
sorry, on the top. You'll see we also
have a radio internet radio station
that's running. But on that one just
click on yeah, on more.
And then here there's two there's a
search function on the top there. You
will see you can WhatsApp Prof word
finder or WhatsApp Prof episode finder.
And if you it's very a very good tool.
You can go and search. If you remember
somewhere or you want to know of
something that for instance speaking in
tongues, you can go to that search now
and you say speaking in tongues and it
will give you all the episodes where
that has been discussed, where that word
has been or spiritual formation or any
word and it'll give you the episode plus
the exact clip where we're speaking
about it. And what you've done now, you
see this there's different ones that
says search exact phrase, include all
words or include any of the words. So
you see there's
it and How did you do that?
And if you click
on that, it will take you it will open
up the YouTube video and it will go to
exactly where that is being said. So
just click on that
Uh someone in the comment section asked
about mysticism. Did y'all cover that
stuff? Yeah, we spoke in a few times,
yeah. Yeah, yeah, oh yeah. So click just
click on on on on one of the icons,
yeah? Click on that one and you'll see
it will go right
And right at the that right at the
place, yeah. Brilliant.
So just This is brilliant. Yeah, that
there's a whole one on spiritual
formation that you can have a go and
have a look at.
>> [laughter]
>> See how easy it was to find?
They ask me, where do you say this? I
haven't got the foggiest clear idea in
what episode I said what, but this tool
helps people to find it.
Friends.
Wow. Um I I got I got no words. I
Yeah, I've been I'm full. I'm definitely
full. Thank you. Thank you.
>> what do you say after that? Like I'm
losing the words.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> [laughter]
>> Let the church say amen.
Thank you. Let the church say amen. Yes.
Were you blessed
like we were?
Uh When you speak about the word of God,
I'm always blessed. I've been blessed
with this whole discussion. Thank you.
And I've watched a few of your videos,
especially when you take on some
some people that have come that are a
bit nasty, and I must commend you on the
way that you always speak to those
people.
Well, that's uh I mean, you know,
Elder Pastor, this was such
a blessing. You have no idea. And
especially talking about those things
that I feel like we don't harp on up,
especially with food and the church
services. It's almost like a taboo topic
cuz nobody wants to talk about it. So, I
thank you guys for the courage to
actually speak on it. Um and I I pray
that somebody who's listening may be
changed. I mean, I know I know
definitely will allow me to kind of
scrutinize what I see a lot more now, to
be honest, because I don't want to be
caught up in that spiritual formation at
all or spiritism. I I I don't want no
part of it. So,
um let us I mean, shall we pray? Yes, I
guess. Thank you very much.
Uh Pastor, would you would you mind
doing the honors of praying for us?
It's a pleasure.
Heavenly Father,
it is always such a blessing
to gather around your word
and all the admonitions that you give us
and the writings in the spirit of
prophecy that help us along the way
to find our way in this dark world with
so many pitfalls.
The devil has devised so many things in
order to distract us, put us onto a
wrong path,
and convince us that we are spiritually
on a high when we are actually feeding
on a spiritual low.
Father in heaven, give us strength and
give us wisdom and give us discernment,
and help us to do the things that you
have prescribed for us in order to aid
us
in obtaining this spiritual discernment.
Things that are simple to do, like
little changes here in diet, being
careful as to what you take into your
body, what you see, what you hear, what
you listen to.
May you May you give us the fortitude
and the strength
to carefully analyze whether we are on
the narrow path
or whether we are straying. Thank you
for all these medias
and our brothers that we we were happy
to talk to and their contribution,
and bless our contribution as well, and
let the message go up that people may
discern the pitfalls in the world out
there, and bless your people is my
prayer in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
>> [music]
[music]